comment suivre à l'école quand on passe
la nuit dans une gare un squat ou une
voiture un dilemme vécu par plusieurs
dizaines d'élèves scolarisés à Tours
selon le collectif pas d'enfants à la
rue ces membres sont parents d'élèves ou
enseignants et ne veulent plus fermer
les yeux sur la situation de ces enfants
et de leur famille depuis la fin mars
ils ont décidé d'agir quand une école se
transforme en hébergement d'urgence
c'est un reportage de Clémence d'OSC
depuis 18h à l'école Michelet un
collectif de parents et enseignants
s'organise pour héberger des élèves et
leurs familles sans abri en un an les
demandes au 115 ont bondit de 30%. le
réseau à la fois des écoles
s'agrandit le réseau des parents et les
enseignants qui souhaitent mettre un
terme à cette situation invivable
s'agrandit aussi donc c'est assez
encourageant de voir cette mobilisation
autour de ce de cette question un réseau
qui a permis de débloquer des chambres
d'hôtel pour deux familles mais deux
autres restent dans l'attente un coup de
fil doit éclairer la situation d'accord
[Musique]
dormir avec la famille deux familles
doivent dormir à l'école ce soir trois
enfants et deux mamans ces derniers
n'ont pas été filmés afin de respecter
leur tranquillité mais leur installation
est similaire à celle des membres du
collectif qui restent sur place pour les
familles c'est aussi frustrant que ça
quoi enfin on est vraiment sur un
matelas posé au fond au fond de la salle
c'est mieux que dormir à la gare ou dans
la rue mais c'est pas beaucoup mieux
je suis des élèves de Sem de et ça fait
plusieurs fois que je suis confronté à
des élèves qui le soir à 16h30 ne savent
pas où ils vont dormir on se substitue
en fait au 115 enfin qui n'a plus de
place en hébergement d'urgence le
collectif a saisi les services de l'État
reçu par la préfecture la semaine
dernière les membres se préparent
maintenant à interpeller le département
parmi les familles aidés des enfants de
moins de 3 ans leur protection relève
des compétences de l'institution
une quarantaine de personnes sont
présentes le lendemain sur le Parvis de
l'Hôtel du Département objectif obtenir
une réponse après des courriers restés
sans retour le Conseil départemental ne
peut pas nous recevoir ce matin qu'il
faudrait envoyer un courrier pour
demander à être reçu avant on n'a pas
fait ça déjà si
la demande n'aboutit pas le collectif ne
compte pas baisser les bras une
mobilisation devrait se tenir la semaine
prochaine pour continuer à faire du
bruit